43 points we are the winners again it
was Sweden's Loreen that took an early
lead and never looked back in Saturday
night's Grand Final in Liverpool
Swede of Moroccan descent pulled in the
votes again and again with a song tattoo
and becomes the first woman and only the
second contestant to ever win the
contest twice she last won in 2012 with
the song Euphoria
in the lead up to the Grand Final the
famous Liverpool Waterfront was filling
up quickly with fans and visitors all
eager to get just a little bit more of
the Eurovision experience the whole city
briefs Eurovision it's so weird like
people walk around people say happy
eurovision's like it's really really
great really well done ukrainians forced
from their home country were also here
grateful the contest was being hosted on
their behalf impressed our gratitude for
every
gather outside the arena the final
technical rehearsals are taking place
for all of the contestants and you can
feel the excitement building up thank
you
while it's all sound light cameras in
action the final lineup of 26 was
whittled down from two semi-finals they
were held earlier in the week and the
inclusion of the host nation Ukraine as
well as the so-called Big Five Germany
Italy Spain France and the UK who get
automatic entry to the final
[Applause]
opened with a poignant Melody and images
reflecting the reality that Ukraine
faces and then a reprise of last year's
winning song from Ukraine's kalush
Orchestra
efficient song contest is now in its
67th year yet still it continues to
entertain more than 160 million viewers
globally with its eclectic mix of
musical genres from toe tabbing ditties
to Crazy stage performances
I did warn you
and then there's this toe tapping tastic
isn't it
let's not forget this one from Portugal
it might not be Riverdance but a lovely
effort dear well done
special effects LED screens pyrotechnics
and hairography accompanied the
finalists in the interval a host of past
performers took to the stage to
entertain the excited veteran Eurovision
fans and viewers watching from across
Europe and Beyond
either one they hope does the votes came
in it was a three-horse race along with
Finland and Israel battling it out for
second and third place the Elijah
Kingdom hosted a spectacular show of
song dance and culture on behalf of
Ukraine now they can pass on the Baton
to Sweden for Eurovision 2024 sahil
Rahman Al Jazeera Liverpool
[Applause]